i want some forest fires like natural
like there's that needs to happen
sometimes to clear a lot of the like
dead trees yeah yeah yeah so obviously a
lot of them recently are like not yeah
so we have we have uh controlled
bushfires uh in australia that happens
like pretty frequently um because we
also have uh
i don't know the the details about it
but we have this specific uh like
is it breed i don't know i don't know
what the word for it is of tree or like
sapling uh where
uh
it's type of eucalyptus i think where
the the the seeds from the tree right
need to be
put into a fire in order to open up
so to keep the forest alive they
actually have to burn these seeds and
basically start a bush fire for that
area of the bush land to grow again
which is like which is the most like
backwards thinking that nature has ever
done it's like look so imagine if like
the dead trees pile up and then it's as
hot as it is in australia yeah it'll
naturally catch oh yeah we got natural
bushfires all the [ __ ] time just
because of how hot and powerful this is
australia literally is like the last
dungeon area like even nature is high
level in australia
randomly just start fighting
it's literally the desert level and
breath of time the breath of the wild
it's literally the desert level and
breath of the wild where like if you
don't have the right equipment you are
forever like just gaining damage from
this yeah i think in israel i think it's
well i can't i might have been one of
those generic vox videos where you learn
about [ __ ] you didn't know you wanted to
learn about and then you learn about it
and you're like okay you're in every
youtube video no mainly vox videos
youtube shorts i always like that so so
i think it was like
because the us for so long was
actively stopping all the fires
it turned out that a lot of the branches
needed to just be set ablaze so that
they can't get rid of them and that it
could go back in the system you know it
turns into ash so they had like a
buildup of a lot of dead dead trees and
stuff like that so when the fire did
start it went like crazy yeah nearly as
big as it was i mean like yeah we think
i could be wrong on that yeah i mean we
have like so many like controlled
bushfires just because we do have like
just at least in my area we have a lot
of like wildlife and like nature
reserves and stuff like that but you
know sometimes unfortunately they're not
you know some of those fires aren't
controlled 100 of the way and that's
what causes bushfire scares and
straight-up bushfires sometimes so i
think that's why we have a lot of that
just because we're trying to maintain
the nature and then sometimes nature's
like you know what i'ma go ham a little
bit
and then they go ham the only controlled
fire in the uk is from trying to boil
your water
oh god
as an australian what is like your
biggest fear over there in terms of like
nature or nature-wise
um like what you have to be careful
about the motion
yeah
honestly the people scare me the most
that's such a video game movie thing
it's not the animation worry about kid
it's the people it's the people humans
are the scariest of them all
the humans were the monsters
you can predict a black widow can't
predict a human
guns don't kill people
people kill people
um in terms of wildlife like i'm usually
pretty okay with like insects and like
snakes and spiders if i know it's not
going to kill me have you ever had like
a big scare yourself of like you've
encountered something you're like oh
this could this [ __ ] could actually oh
yeah yeah many times like i've i've
thought the health bar comes on the
bottom of the screen
yeah many times like uh i remember
i was actually this close to
basically dying at one point uh because
i was this close to being bitten by uh
bitten by one of the most venomous ants
in the world
yeah so we not only so australia so
people outside of australia think that
australia is just like yeah venomous uh
spiders and snakes
yeah we have a lot of uh venomous
insects and we have this one ant uh
species called the bulldog ant
and uh it is
supposedly the most venomous ant in the
world and i almost got bitten by one
when i was like 10 years old right i
think
like dark souls is like way more
balanced than australia at least it has
like a hitbox you can see so basically
yeah so basically like i was i was
camping uh you know that's where most of
the accidents happen so you got the
campfire right that makes sense yeah no
i was i was camping on fire and i was
like sitting here
i lit the bonfire i thought i was in the
safe zone and i wasn't you know the one
enemy
before i could teleport um yeah so i was
like kind of sitting around the fire
with uh you know my family and my mates
and uh i was like maybe 10 11 years old
and we were in like a really really like
deep rainforest area right yeah so it
was like you know basically we just
found like a fl it wasn't even like a a
registered campsite basically it was
just like oh we found a flat piece of
ground yeah let's just you know start a
fire here you know as long as it's
controlled
i like it the way he just said
responsible yeah
he didn't say let's let's make this our
campsite yeah yeah that's not a fire
yeah i mean i've been a responsible
firefighter yeah yeah a small fighter
let's not let's notify here let's let's
let's hunker down here for the night all
right yeah let's uh so we set up the
camp there and you know my dad started
the fire and you know we were getting
all cozied up and uh i was sitting on
this like giant slab of rock right okay
right that was like very smooth and you
know as like a 10 year old you just want
to like climb [ __ ] right it's like
you know i found lots of little rocks to
like and big rocks to kind of climb
around in and i was sitting and i was
kind of sitting with my mate as well and
my hand was like rested back like this
right okay kind of like legs out right
kind of thing
and i was just chilling and everything
and then i felt
something crawl onto my hand right
and i looked down and it was an ant
but i was like oh that's a that's a big
ant but how big we're talking um like
like that that's quite big yeah that's
pretty i mean that's still an ant yeah
you know it's still an air
this is this is this this pitch black
ant uh just kind of like crawling onto
my finger
um
and then uh yeah and then i kind of like
put my hand up and was looking at it and
then my friend who was next to me
just gasped and then [ __ ] immediately
swatted my hand away and swatted this
ant off me right and i was like what the
[ __ ] i was looking at this cool land
why would you do that and he was like
dude you could have died like you do
know what that thing is right and then
he told me and he showed me uh what it
was i was like
well thank you for slapping my hand um
glad i didn't die yeah does it
definitely kill you or is it like i mean
it's like it's like it can kill they say
the venom is powerful enough to like
kill an adult in like 15 minutes so
as a 10 year old uh probably would have
been like instant was the uh coyote
peterson video of him yeah right
yeah
the sting test i already know will then
kill me
that's the next level of bomb
youtube days it's like will it blend
like 20 30 youtube will i die i die
will i die let's find out
yeah so uh yeah so basically my my
friend saved my life and uh now i'm
now i know that we have these ants
because you know
yeah when you're because you know when
you're a kid in australia you know
you're always you know told like you
know be careful of the snakes be careful
the spiders because you know we do have
a lot of non-venomous kinds yeah but you
know that's not the ones you have to
look out for obviously like you know
i've been bitten by snake once but it
wasn't venomous it just really [ __ ]
hurt right so that i mean that's fine it
was just like a little nip on the finger
so it's whatever um you know what
doesn't kill you what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger right they must have
sent the craziest [ __ ] from the
uk
if i was if i was like they're one of
the first people in australia and one of
my friends just gets bitten by an end
and we're like laughing jovial and then
just dies i'm like we're leaving
[ __ ] this place get back on the boat
we're leaving
[Applause]
the dark continents in hunt
that's when you play the ground as lava
you know like it's like everybody off
the ground yeah the dark history
yeah i don't think i'd have like the
courage to do anything in australia
because like they're not the more i read
the more i'm just like well i just i
guess i just won't go outside
it's great the beaches sound great until
i read about like [ __ ] stone fish
right and then i'm just like oh i mean
it's a stone fish just you know just
don't [ __ ] step on the way
okay so a stone fish is a fish that
looks exactly like a stone it's very
ugly fish it's a very like a bottom
dweller yeah but its fins have razor
sharp needles that if you step on it
it's apparently one of the most painful
like experiences you can have from an
animal yeah from an animal have any of
your friends stepped on one uh i've had
a friend step on one uh
and uh he oh i mean he obviously went to
the [ __ ] hospital for he didn't die
but
well that's a plus but i mean he didn't
die
painful it's just extremely painful i
mean if you it could cause like
anaphylactic shock and like kill you if
you're unlucky you know like like the
most venomous fish
yeah it's the most famous fish known on
earth um and so even if i don't even if
you don't die you're going to have a
very very bad time yeah you're just
going to experience a lot i mean if
you're experiencing enough water what's
the pain is it because it's sharp or is
it like got some poison probably got
some toxins in it or something right
yeah it can kill you
it can kill you okay just like pull up
the glock shoot your own foot yeah
stop it stop her from going through it
cut it off
i mean like you know i think but like
things like stone fish and like you know
are they super common or is it super no
it's very very rare